الجامعه العربيه اصلا يعني ادت الدوره
اللي اصلا من مناطم بها يعني ما نتوقع
منها حتى توقع منها شيء غير انها بيت
اجتماع على العربيات رمزي لكن مجلس
التعاون الخليجي هو الذي طرح عدد من
المثقفين في منطقه الخليج فكره الوحده
الخليجيه الحقيقه انا برايي انها ضد منطقه
تاريخ ضد منطقه الجغرافيا كل واحد له حدود
الوحده تعني الغاء الحدود اذا تقول ان
الوحده لا تعني الغاء الحدود فاللقايه من
الان هو وحده انت ضد مساله اتحاد الخليجي
او الاتحاد
معنى خطير جدا المعنى له رمزيته له خطر
الوحده تعني الغاء الحدود واذا ما تصير
وحده
اذا الحدود قائمه
فاللي جالس وتعاون وتالف مجلس التعاون
الخليجي اسمه اسمه مجلس التعاون هذا
المصطلح وهو مصطلح صحيح هو المصطلح
الطبيعي له يحصل خلافات وكم حصل خلافات
بين دول الخليج التي استطاعوا احتواء
الخلافات سنه سنتين ثلاث اربع بس يظلون
يستطيعون يحترمونها ما يحصل انفكاك كامل
لانها لو كانت وحده حصل انفصال زي ما حصل
بين سوريا ومصر لو كانت وحده حصل انفصام
واعداء مثل ما حصل بين العراق سوريا الغاء
فكره الوطن
الحدود معه الارض تنتقم لنفسه نفسها
وتهشم المعنى الذي ظن انه مثالي وجيد وهو
ليس كذالك لذلك ما ما ممكن احنا نشهد
واقعيه شيء اسمه واحده بمعنى الغاء حدود
سبيل الله اما التعاون يعني
التقارب ما بين السعوديه والامارات نموذج
من ارقى النماذج في العالم العربي
لكن ما هي وحده كل واحد قائم بذاته وكل
واحد يراعي مصلحته ويختلف وين احيانا على
مسائل المصالح ثم يتفقون او يضلل الاختلاف
وكل واحد فاهم الاخر فهذا المعنى الذي و
الدول العربيه حاولت او جابها ومجلس
التعاون الى العربي هل هو مصر والعراق
وجابوا مجلس التعاون المغاربي لم ينجح اي
منهم على ما عندهم الاراده
والتماثل الذهني واضح ما بينهم عندنا احنا
تماثل ذهني بين الانظمه الحكم
في الدول